Remote Control, now you can play the only game show that started in a basement right on your Nintendo Entertainment System.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. And I'm Sean.
It's just the two of us today, which is unfortunate because it is one of those weird three-player game shows.
There are a bunch of them.
I'm not sure who decided three is better than two or four, but I guess maybe it makes the final round thing more interesting when there's not just one versus the other.
Now that I think about it, though, it's not weird that it's a three-player game show.
Most game shows are three players.
So instead, I'm going to divert that silly statement and just talk about the back of the box for a second because I do think there was a missed opportunity there.
It said, now you can play the only game show that started in a basement right on and it should have been right in your basement, right?
Like, I feel like that would have been better than just like right on your...
I feel like I just read a statement that anybody could have put together.
The basement thing would have been a little more clever copywriting.
So that's my editorial note for this episode.
Yeah, I'd say that, you know, it would have been more like, you know, that whole like play video games in your basement thing.
I think that really didn't come on until the late, like the mid-aughts, or maybe the early aughts, when the whole like neck beard basement dweller meme started to take shape.
Like, the NES was in the living room.
Or you know what? It was in the family room.
Yes, the family room.
That is a great point, Sean, because remember, it is just the family computer over in Japan, but it's also the entertainment system here.
It's supposed to be all-encompassing, even if it just has really a gun, a dance pad, and a robot.
Those are all fun things for the family.
Every American family wants a gun, a robot, and a dance pad.
I sure do, still.
Now, were you aware that remote control was going to be anything related to a game show that happened to also be a real game show on MTV?
Or were you expecting, I don't know, I was expecting a RC Pro-Am-like game where you drive remote control cars, or maybe you fiddle with an NES controller and it's your remote control.
Anyway, what were you thinking?
I had no idea that this was a game show, let alone an MTV game show.
So, I sort of figured that it was going to be something like a TV-themed side-scroller, and there'd be weird...
I don't know what I'm trying to describe here.
There'd be lots of the colored bars in the background, and that'd be the things that you jump on.
I don't know if you're going to get stuck in a TV, or if it was based off of a really obscure 80s movie.
But I figured there was going to be something along those lines, and not a game show.
Yeah, and what's weird is that this isn't a game show that you'll find again, or hear about really again.
In fact, while the video game version is coming out, the game show on MTV is being cancelled.
So, it's like a really bad time to release the game, I guess, unless they're saying, like,
we're cancelling the game show on TV because now anybody can play it anywhere.
We've reached peak remote control because the premise of the show is that Ken Ober, the host,
wants to be a game show host like his idols, who he has pictures of all over the basement.
And so, he set up a game show in his basement, has three people in these kind of, like, lazy boy-like chairs.
I can't tell if they're supposed to be, like, strapped against their will or not, or if they're just happy to be there.
That part wasn't clear to me.
But then, like, you know, you're just playing trivia from a TV where you tune into what they're calling TV channels,
but are really categories.
And categories are based on either TV shows or pop culture-related things.
And that's always a recipe for success, something that will never age poorly.
Everybody will always understand these questions for infinity, right?
You definitely got every single thing they were referencing when you got to the trivia portions.
Yeah, I'll be honest.
I didn't really get many of these.
Probably the majority, no.
But, like, did you watch this show at all?
I'd never heard of the show before this, but yes, I did wind up pulling up.
I think there's, like, a full episode available on YouTube.
Oh, there's a lot.
Okay, great. Yeah, sorry.
I just, like, Googled it, and I pulled up the episode from June 28th, 1989.
So what I watched was just about as strange, stylistically, as the NES game that we're playing.
So what I thought was a series of, like, you know, weird art direction decisions actually are totally on brand for the show itself.
Yeah, so I was kind of pleasantly surprised with the show, like, the real show.
Like, it had a young Colin Quinn on it, which I thought was strange.
I just remember him being, like, a really upset, like, asshole on Comedy Central with, like, a tough crowd.
And then, like, what's his, uh, Adam Sandler makes appearances.
I've never recognized the actual, like, uh, host.
But, yeah, it does, it does, like, bear some resemblances in how it's presented.
But I, it, it's definitely just a very abridged version of that.
Like, most of what goes on in this show is sort of trying to be encapsulated into, um, when you select a category in the game, it'll have some, like, off-color remark about stuff.
And then the same kind of humor in the, uh, in the actual channel names or, uh, categories.
Yeah, there's, like, a sketch comedy component to the whole thing where there's not, like, a overarching plot through the episode, per se.
No. But, uh, there is a, um, you know, it's more than just, uh, Jeopardy, pick the category, here's the question.
There's a lot of, uh, and I can't tell you if it's improv or scripted or not, but there's a lot of work that goes into, uh, the setup here, which makes this kind of, uh, I guess, you know, what MTV was going for was, like,
this is the new kind of game show, right?
Yeah. This is, like, it's game show plus comedy.
Very irreverent and, like, breaking the rules of game shows.
Like, maybe this was the first one.
I don't know. Maybe there, maybe it wasn't.
But it seems like, oh, this, this is, like, it's not your parents' game show.
You know, very MTV, like, uh, of them to do it.
Yes. And, you know, there's a, there's a very weird aesthetic to the whole thing as well.
Both the show and the video game, um, there's a lot of just, you know, it's because it's in, it's in a basement, but there's a giant Pez dispenser of the guy who was the host of the newlywed show.
There's, um, uh, that you, when you, uh, when you lose, your chair goes flinging through, uh, what I imagine is a very easily breakable wall, uh, to be ejected from.
From, and, uh, there's the, the game show host's mother kind of, like, chimes in from time to time.
Oh, didn't know that. Yeah, not, not in our-
That must have been season two. Yeah, it wasn't in our video game, uh, either, uh, to the best of my knowledge.
That's the thing.
So, we're missing, I think that's what we're missing in the video game.
Yeah. Format here is we're missing a lot, like, they're still trying to, I don't know, it's like aggressive, self-deprecating humor in, in the video game still, but there isn't the, uh, the sort of sketch comedy or, um, you know, intricacy of the actual show.
I don't know, it doesn't even really look like it's in a basement, right?
Like, I get that those are couches that they're sitting on, but it doesn't really feel like we, you know, put us in a basement that's recognizable.
Give me a washer dryer or something.
Uh, yeah, the, so when they're, when they're showing the contestants like that looks, it looks close.
But when you're showing the host, like the TV's right, the TV, cause it's like so, uh, off the wall design and like very, uh, exaggerated.
But everything else is just like, there wasn't just a scrolling like MTV, uh, banner in the back that was just a bunch of MTV logos.
It was still like the same kind of set design and it, it kind of looked like a missed opportunity there.
And MTV and trademarks and, um, incorporated things are like all over this.
There's so much like legal stuff on, on this game where like MTV is both on the trivia thing as a like repeating banner.
It's, uh, it's also like the remote control trademark is everywhere.
I don't know if you need like the trademark in game.
Like I get that you need that on the legal screen, but it just feels weird to have it all over the place.
And while we're talking about, uh, kind of, I guess like the legalities and everything, this game does have a very, uh, funny accompanying manual.
Oh. That, that gets into a lot of that too.
And so I, I'm sure you, this is probably one that you didn't read.
And I don't know what I read.
I don't know why I thought to read it.
I think I was just checking to see how, like, how it works with more than one player.
Uh, so I was going to the manual, but it's very like in the same style as the host of the show, that kind of person talking to you about the stuff in the manual.
Cause you know, usually we get like, don't leave your game on for this amount of time and like very things that like are required by people.
But instead this one had like, uh, you know, press start when you see the legal mumbo jumbo on the screen.
It's like, okay.
Like that's, that's funny.
That's funny. Yeah.
It's funny enough.
And I think that's another thing I want to get into is like, it's funny enough.
The show, the show, you know, give or take, maybe the humor didn't age that well, but like the actual video game just isn't funny enough period.
Like, it's not like it, it's not like the jokes just don't land because we don't understand them.
It's just not, it's not actually funny.
It's almost as that same problem that a double dare had where double dare is like a fun game to play because of all the wacky stuff that happens.
But in the NES version, like nothing wacky happened.
Yeah. The whole, the whole like thing about the show is the, is how kind of, it feels unscripted, at least the one I watched.
And it sounds like the one you watched too.
And there's like jostling back and forth, like kind of poking fun at the contestants from like the peanut gallery with, yeah, Colin Quinn and what, whoever they all else are.
Um, and then you got like the, the guest presenters that come in for certain categories and that all just sort of boils down to a, like the coat of paint is this MTV show.
But like the gameplay itself is just a three answer, like trivia game.
There's really not much in the, in the gameplay that feels like it.
Yeah. Essentially, once you've had, once you've seen what the game has to offer, then it really just survives based on the, the trivia categories and how much you like TV.
Because a lot of, almost all of this is focused on, uh, television sitcoms and pop culture stuff.
And soap operas for some reason.
There's a lot of soap opera stuff.
That was the strangest part because it's like MTV doesn't even have a hand in those kinds of things.
So it's not, you know, their audience isn't watching soap operas and they're not like owned yet by anybody who was like, you know, making affiliate soap operas.
So I'm not sure where that comes from, but yeah, I don't know anything about General Hospital.
Don't ask me any General Hospital questions.
It's funny because when, when the episode of the show that I watched, which is now just like, that is the entire like, over of the show.
Like there's not three seasons of this, um, there was a soap opera category.
So apparently maybe just like soap operas were, were much bigger and more a part of the zeitgeist back then.
Um, but yeah, it wasn't made up for the video game at least.
Or are they just not thinking about how many other things TV could offer?
Like sports are on TV.
Where's like, give me a lot of sports categories.
You, you know, you put, put, put a news category on or something for news events.
Like you can stretch the definition of what's on TV, right?
Just because you've made your categories TV channels.
Uh, Gen X's didn't watch the news, Mike.
Like that. But they watched, they watched all my children.
Maybe. Who am I to say?
All right. So even though the game isn't funny, I'm going to go back to the manual because it is funny.
And it has a note here on the section where you're picking your character, which is handled very strangely in the game.
But, um, I'm not going to complain about it because there's other things to talk about.
Yeah, I agree. You're really just selecting the face that you want to be.
And so you, you, you choose, you know, the, the face and none of the faces look good.
So don't worry about that.
Uh, but it's on purpose.
Yeah. It has, uh, one of the steps on like getting started to play has like how you choose which,
you know, which face you want to be.
And it, you know, tries to be funny there, but then it has a little note at the bottom.
Note to ugly contestants.
If you don't like the way you look after seeing the competition, don't panic.
You can cycle back to your little TV using the arrow keys and change to someone else.
Too bad. It's not so easy off the screen.
Hey. Yeah.
Again, you see what I'm saying?
It's like the game is like very aggressive at like you suck and your life.
Nobody, nobody envies you and, uh, your play video games in your basement.
Like it has that kind of culture behind it, even though as we just established the video
game consoles more in the family room right now.
So I just feel like this game is trying to be, um, overly hip, uh, but wasn't, but didn't
have the same writers attached to it that the actual show had.
And it needed that.
Yeah. And I think though, that that might be like very realistic because, and again, this is
me viewing it from 30 odd years later, but it, I think the show was also trying to be
too hip. Uh, so that's actually sort of truth in television right there.
Um, did you know that the, whatever happens to you, like at the end of the second, um,
the end of the second section was, did you know that that was, um, popcorn popcorn?
Did you do the stuff that falls around and like goes all over the place?
No, I did not know that that was popcorn.
I didn't know until I watched an episode.
Um, but it was that stuff that was flying around the legal screen and then it happens
in the game and like, what the hell?
Like, is this a thing that they do every episode?
I didn't know what it was supposed to be, but it's, I think it's like popcorn or cereal.
I don't know. Yeah.
Sorry. That was another aside.
I'm not sure if that even adds up, but again, like now that's not basement.
That's a, that's kitchen material.
Yeah. It should have been like a burst pipe.
Uh, yeah. So we should get into the flow of the game.
Um, as I mentioned, there's three contestants.
You're answering questions about different categories, soap operas.
Sure. Or, and so there's two rounds of gameplay and in the, in either round, it doesn't really
matter just the points and, and such, but in each round of that gameplay, you pick a TV
channel from the giant TV.
I think there's nine channels.
And, uh, once you pick that channel, you get the, um, you know, the category and then
anybody, it's anybody's chance to answer the question.
Uh, which, which, uh, is an interesting thing because it, it, it allowed me to, uh, control
the game a lot more often than like watching the computers win and just continue to select
questions and, and get the opportunity to answer.
If you know what I mean? Like there are some shows or some trivia formats where if, you know, if you just get stuck with
like, and you know, the winner goes on until they can't answer a question.
Uh, double dare even has that a little bit.
Like if you're not dared, you might have to wait for the computer to get one wrong.
I like that you have the opportunity to just buzz in quickly, answer the question.
And then the timers are aggressive, thankfully, because they figured out that we're not going
to try to have anybody type in these things.
It's just multiple choice, which is, which is obviously the way to go for a video game.
Uh, especially when it's eight bit, I'm, I'm glad that we saw it here.
Uh, any thoughts on not the quality of the questions themselves, but the, the format?
Um, well, I guess I haven't really seen too many game shows where only the, like the picker
can answer. Like I'm used to the Jeopardy style where it's just like, you can pick the category, but
everyone's going to get a chance to answer.
So I guess I'm glad that they stuck, they stuck with that.
Um, and I don't know if the multiple choice thing, like I think multiple choice is fine,
but I think you need like a couple more options because you can really just guess your way
through this. And I think if I'm playing against somebody that just gets lucky guessing one of three
things, like that's, that's not really trivia.
Trivia, that's just being a good test taking.
So the actual, uh, execution of the trivia, I think a little bit to be desired there.
Yeah. You have a 33% chance of just guessing, right?
Because there's only three options.
Uh, four would have been fine, I suppose, but also, uh, and probably more importantly,
the, uh, one of the, one of the selected answers is usually not always, but it's usually like
a joke answer too.
That's very easy to kind of decipher and be like, well, yeah, it's not that one.
Um, not always of course, but that's, that's the entirety of the, uh, the game show because
even when you finally do get to the third round, the lightning round, I think what they call the
think real fast round, um, that is still a, you know, a format of the same thing where you're
being asked a question and then you are both able to simultaneously answer and whoever answers
first, uh, you know, wins, uh, you know, that's like, that's an interesting twist on answering
questions, like a new way to answer said questions, but it's not really like, it's not different
for the sake of, uh, what the game is offering.
And so realistically throughout the entirety of your gameplay experience, you are doing nothing
more, uh, in this game other than just, uh, selecting facts on a screen, you know?
And I think that's not what a video game was designed for.
I think, uh, that's a really harsh way to say it.
But I think it's okay. Yeah.
I mean, you know, cause I was thinking about this in general, not even just for game show
games, but just in general for video games.
What, what does it need?
But like, what do you actually think a video game needs to not just be on our essential
games list, but to be considered like a good game and everything.
And I don't think just emulating what, what worked on TV is going to like, you know, think
about it. If the Rugrats video game, which doesn't exist, I don't know why I went to them, but I guess
I got Nickelodeon on the mind from work.
If the Rugrats video game was you just watch an episode, but in video game format, right?
Like, that's not a video game either.
Like, yeah, that's how the show worked.
But you know, it's like, you don't have like, instead you want to put yourself in a brand
new adventure. And obviously like, it's tougher with a game show, but there needed to be something more
here. Just like there needs to be more in the wheel of fortune and jeopardy video games.
Like I'm not being, I guess I'm just saying in general, like multiple choice trivia games.
No, you know, I'm going to offer you so much.
I'm not going to go into the muddy waters of saying what defines a video game, because
I think we could start yelling at each other if it goes down a certain route.
But when it comes to something like this, like in my opinion, the wheel of fortune games are
actually really good at being wheel of fortune.
It is a very easy game to sort of systematize there.
And jeopardy is not terrible either.
Like, yeah, it's kind of annoying that you got to type it all in and like the computers
will either get it right or completely just glitch out.
But at least like that's still the game from your perspective.
It's either right or wrong.
And like you're playing jeopardy.
Like in this, you're not playing remote control on MTV and remote control on MTV.
They don't give you a bunch of a bunch of multiple choice questions.
And you just have to pick between the three options in remote control.
The video game, there aren't the like sort of more visual questions or categories where
you actually have to look at a TV screen and tell and tell them what that is.
Like none of that's in here.
So this isn't even a really good emulation of the TV show as you described it.
This is actually porting a TV show into trivial pursuit.
It doesn't even have the going through the wall with the chairs for elimination.
Instead, you get like, yeah, you get lightning.
Yeah, you get lightning strikes, which is, I don't know.
I guess that's weirder thing to happen in a basement, right?
Like that's, I definitely think that that's a little alarming, but I don't know.
I would have preferred to just stick to the show format, right?
Of going through the breakable wall.
Like that's fun. Well, that would require some animation.
Right. And we can't be expected of that.
What else was I say?
But you know, one thing it does have that the show had to, but I guess does offer a little
bit of a switch up is that certain channels are, I guess, like special channels that aren't
just the normal TV categories.
Instead, you'll have to like answer a math problem or you'll just automatically lose 10
points when you select the home shopping zone channel.
Like, uh, you see, you see my problem here is like that this was a chance for the video
game version to the special channel, like is more interactive because you're playing an
interactive medium.
Yeah. But instead they still just chose to make it like, actually these special channels are even
more simple than the multiple choice ones because now you're either just doing, you know,
generic math or you're not even doing anything.
We're just telling you what's happened.
Yeah. I think one thing that I do appreciate the game doesn't do is just even bother pretending
that you're going to be excited to win like a 32 by eight picture of a car like in and like
you don't have to cycle through that like, oh, you win this cruise that you don't
actually get to take.
Like, I know that that that's still something that like weirdly bothers me, but I'm glad
it's not here.
Right. Yeah.
Instead, you're just the winner.
You're just the winner.
That's fine. That's all you got to be.
So what's the goal here for MTV?
Is it just like brand recognition?
Because keep in mind, like the show probably wasn't announced to be canceled, but is is
canceled. The game, you know, like it's not about syndication reruns or whatever.
Is it just about getting that MTV logo all over a video game and making sure that like
you make some final sales on this now defunct IP?
You got to assume that when they like greenlit the video game that they hadn't already canceled
it and they had already put the resources into the game and, you know, just to make their
money back, they released it.
That's what I have to guess.
I totally believe that both can be true as somebody who now works at the, you know, what
is it? Sister network of one of these.
Parent? Well, yeah, the parent come.
We're both owned by the same parent.
So you're the sister of the parent's child.
There you go. Yeah. That's the name of the movie.
The sister of the parent's child.
That would make you the aunt.
Never mind. Go ahead. Anyway.
No, what I was going to say is I believe that it's totally possible that one department,
the games department says, all right, our next game we're going to make is the remote
control game show.
And they never check or talk to the production team who then, you know, is full swing, just
not making another season.
And so when it comes out, that's when the that's when like everybody finally finds out
about it. And it's just one of those things that like the next day in the office, you're just
like, oh, no, but nobody really cares.
That's what happens at my company all the time, too.
There's just like a lot of corporate miscommunication.
But we're not we're not here talking about like bad things that our company does, you
know? No, of course not.
And I don't think back then a remote control was really a hotly debated topic either at
the MTV studios, right?
Do you think they cared if they put out a good game or not?
The game got released.
It sold some some copies shortly.
And everybody walked off happier except for the people who probably bought the game.
Is this the essential games list?
What's happening right now?
Is there anything else you want to talk about?
You know, without talking about the show, because this isn't this isn't a review of the
show, which I think you're saying you found pretty decent.
I enjoyed it.
Mine. My version on YouTube came complete with commercials as well.
So I enjoyed seeing with the commercials.
I really enjoyed seeing those old commercials.
And I didn't know that MTV was playing like Coors Light commercials.
I would think that they weren't allowed to do that because it's like you have a Coors Light
commercial followed by a Coca-Cola commercial.
And it's like, like, what's the audience here?
Right. Teens. So I'm going to take the opportunity you've given me after explicitly asking me not to
talk about the actual television show and then proceeding to talk about the television
show to talk about the television show one more time.
The last time I really liked the prizes, the actual prizes that you got.
Um, cause again, the show's marketed towards like young people.
Um, so one of the prizes is like a pair of Ray-Bans, which I thought was strange because
like this is a game show, not like a county fair.
So I was, it was weird to see that the first prize is something as like mundane as a pair
of sunglasses. Maybe they're really expensive.
I don't know. Um, and then there's a typewriter because, you know, college kids need a typewriter because
they're not, they're not going to bring home, like they're not going to put like a Commodore
in there and they're to like write stuff that has some kind of printing unit.
Right. So there's a typewriter.
Um, and then, uh, it kind of like, like, you know, there's boom boxes, something very
eighties, nineties.
And then there's a car if you get all the stuff right at the end.
But I just, I just thought it was funny.
Like I, I kind of forget that a lot of TV shows didn't have a crazy budget for the actual
prizes. And do you think that they made the contestants dress up like idiots?
Oh no, no, no.
That's just, that was a style.
That was the style of the time.
Cool. No, cause I'm just saying like, you know, as we mentioned the video game version of these
people, like their faces are also kind of all like smushed up and, uh, smushed up is
actually perfect. I'm not even going to expand on that.
They really, they really do look smushed.
Something's going on there.
Young people in the late eighties, early nineties do just looked weird.
Like, I don't know if it was the haircuts.
I know a lot of our listeners are of this age group, so I'm not going to be too harsh,
but I mean, you know, you could say the thing, the same thing about, about us back in the
day. Everyone looked weird when they were younger.
You know what the remote control video game might be better than though?
Go on.
The remote control board game.
There was one.
I saw it at the end of my episode.
They were advertising, uh, don't, you know, don't miss your chance to take remote control
home with the remote control board game.
So the board game did come out before the video game, but now like all of the pressure
of being a funny host is on you, right?
Like at home, like at least the video game version, like you're not hosting.
I think they sold it, um, specifically at like improv groups.
Like you, like you had to get the, the, the actual board game to join like the improv troop.
One time I went to, uh, like a board game bar down in Atlanta and I was like really excited
by the prospect of that, but it was really just a bar with a bunch of board games.
You know, like it wasn't like, oh, people come here to play those board games.
They just have board games and the board game that they had that I was like, I just have
to find out how the hell this works is the family ties board game.
And you know, the show with Michael J Fox.
Um, and I just was like, it was one of those things where I look at the box and I'm like,
how, what is the game?
Like I was just so intrigued by that.
Is it just family ties trivia?
No, it's a, I'm sure that that's worked in there at some point or another, but, uh,
uh, no, it's, it's just a really stupid, complicated game for no reason.
And there's a bunch of these apparently like a bunch of sitcoms got board games because
that was another way to like make money off your property.
But, but, you know, I think that's what I'm going to get to in the essential games list.
And what I was getting to just a second ago is that, you know, when you have an established
intellectual property that you then bring into the video game space, it doesn't have
to be shameless.
And I'm not saying that, uh, there's nothing redeeming about this.
Heck, if you ever wanted to see the Brady Bunch and, uh, applied physics put together
for trivia questions, well, I got news for you.
This game has it. This game has a whole thing where you don't need to know anything about the Brady Bunch other
than I suppose the names of the characters.
You're just answering physics questions.
That's not a category.
That doesn't rely any trivia.
That's no different than the math questions.
Uh, my point being that, you know, if, if you are a, uh, an established property, when
you bring something else into the fold, it has to add to that.
How does it like enhance or add or what does it do?
And the video game really doesn't do anything.
It could, it doesn't have to exist and it's, it's better off that I didn't know that this
game was a thing.
Just like I didn't need to know that the game show was a thing because it's never rerun
since it was off the air.
Uh, yeah, this is going to be a note from me.
Sean? Yeah.
I mean, it's, it's not essential.
Um, this is an obvious cash grab.
Um, there really isn't much love for the show, even in the game.
Like there's, there's some stuff that makes it feel like it a little bit.
Like I, I might throw the show on randomly on YouTube now because I think that like this
kind of obscure really speaks to me and it does have some people that I do recognize on
there, but that's just another form of borrowed nostalgia.
There's nothing to do with this game, which is not good.
I was wondering when Adam Sandler joined Saturday Night Live.
Um, it seems like it was after this.
So that's kind of cool. You can, you get your chance at a young Adam Sandler on, uh, the TV show version of remote
control. Uh, he's funny.
He's funny when he's young.
Uh, I saw one of his like first standups ever on YouTube and I was like, man, he's,
he's got like a different rhythm and cadence to himself and carries himself.
Like he hates his life.
It was like, it's kind of funny.
Like now he's like, yeah, I'll shoot any movie as long as I get to go on vacation with my
kids while I'm on the movie.
It depends on what modern movie you're talking about.
He can still nail hates his life wallowing.
Yeah. In fact, actually even in those movies, right.
The vacation movies with the kids, he still manages to do it.
Uh, you know, this game was also worth it for the manual though.
I would say, honestly, if you're a fan of remote control, read the manual.
Uh, that's probably, you know, part of the lore.
Uh, that'll help enhance, you know, like that'll help enhance your remote control experience
more than playing the game would.
Next week we'll be playing adventures in the magic kingdom.
Uh, so we're going to Disney world, I guess, baby.
Just kidding. Just kidding. Just kidding